make one grade movie not bad make two
great movies impressive three grade
movies I bow before you mr. Affleck Argo
is the true story that takes place
during the Iranian hostage crisis that
was in the late 70s to early 80s his
movies directed by Ben Affleck and stars
him as well it's about this one guy
completely true story it was actually
Declassified in the 90s by Bill Clinton
they're trying to come up with an idea
to get these six hostages out of Iran
and Ben atha goes hey what if we pretend
like we're making a fake movie like this
science fiction fantasy film called Argo
we go there we pretend like these six
people are part of our film crew and we
fly them out of there as if we were just
scouting the locations and it's one of
those so crazy that it just might work
schemes that they decide to go for it
it's a really intense dramatic thriller
very realistic and in my opinion one of
the best films of the year Ben Affleck
you are amazing my friend you are one of
the best directors we have working today
when he made Gone Baby Gone I was so
impressed with that movie it was so good
and when he made the town it was maybe
even better with Argo he leaves the
comfort zone of Boston he goes for a
very realistic subject something that
actually happened and he succeeds with
flying colors it has a great sense of
realism to the drama you can tell they
got a lot of their facts straight
there's certain times in the movie where
you're like yeah I totally heard about
that that's actually what happened and
it just it feels very authentic the
performances are excellent this is one
of Ben Affleck's better performances
because he's very subdued in this movie
where an actor would normally take on a
role like this of this American hero you
know you feel like you might want to
overdo it sometimes or get a little too
forthcoming or enthusiastic with your
performance you know really I'm going to
nail this scene I'm going to be I'm
gonna be so good in this scene but he is
so toned down in this movie that I
really think it's one of his best
performances and maybe oscar-worthy
because there's nothing in this movie
about his performance that screams like
wow that would be so difficult to do as
an actor but it really actually is very
difficult for an actor to hone himself
so well to a role and to fight that urge
to want to be really big in a scene he's
definitely the most subdued of all the
actors in this movie and he gives a
really nuanced performance I was really
impressed also good as Bryan Cranston
which is like a cliche for me to say
that because he's such a good actor he's
been like everything this year he's been
in so many movies but he was really
really good here I really liked his
scenes this movie was so tense that my
heart was beating at times I could feel
my my palms clenching in my fists were
tightening it was just it was a really
great thriller there's a whole other
side of this movie though I haven't
mentioned yet and it's this very funny
side to it that pokes fun at the
Hollywood cliches of how the town works
and everything and how actors view
themselves big shots and you can really
tell that although Ben Affleck is a
famous actor it seems like he got famous
doing stuff like daredevil and paycheck
and all those movies that were just you
know very cliched and conventional
Hollywood entertainment and now he's
taken that famous 'no stood he has along
with his Oscar he got for screenwriting
he's making things that matter he's
actually making movies entertainment
that matter it's actually kind of
impressive you can see him inserting his
views on Hollywood into the film and I
really like that John Goodman is so good
in this movie and you know who else is
great is Alan Arkin if you guys have
ever seen wait until dark with Audrey
Hepburn from 1967 Alan Arkin has been
knocking it out of the park for decades
and he is so good in this movie John
Goodman and him have some of the best
scenes in the whole movie it's it's some
of the most entertaining scenes in the
film for sure the film was intense it
was dramatic it was well acted it was
heartfelt it was very touching
I loved Argo I really think it's one of
the better films of the year definitely
see it I'm gonna give Argo in a good job
Ben Affleck man you are continuously
impressing me thanks a lot for watching
guys and as always if you like this then
you can click right here and get stuck
my eyes
Oh